tonight
on brian ross investigates new
allegations
that senior officials at usa swimming
failed to crack down on coaches
accused of grooming young swimmers as
sex objects
these texts sent to a 13 year old girl
by her coach
only thing they did was cover it up with
new reports that federal prosecutors
have opened a criminal investigation
into usa swimming officials still won't
talk with us
about what they're doing to fix the
problem can you answer that question sir
plus with concerns that isis may be
resurrected
as u.s forces pull back from syria it's
never in our national security interest
to abandon an ally who's helped us fight
isis
we'll hear from the mother of james
foley the american journalist who was
murdered by the terrorists
might his killers be able to escape
justice
and our shoutout for the reporter in
minnesota who
uncovered the shocking reality of
midwestern teens
caught up in sex trafficking rings i
need help
what kind of help do you mean there's
three people trying to prostitute me
why are the state's judges going easy on
some of the men responsible not a single
judge in the state
would talk with us from the law and
crime network studios
in new york city's herald square this
is brian ross investigates
good evening and welcome tonight new
development in a story i've been
following for almost a decade
the sexual abuse of young teenage
swimmers at the hands of their coaches
in clubs across the country all over
seen by the parent group
usa swimming parents send their children
to these clubs many in hopes their sons
and daughters
will find glory in the sport perhaps
even emerge as the next
olympic stars for the american team
instead all too many find their children
groomed by their coaches
who see the young athletes as sexual
prey with a number of them now taking
usa swimming to court and a new report
that federal prosecutors have opened a
criminal investigation
go go go the swim club in stockton
california has been considered one of
the best in the country
parents proud of their sons and
daughters posting videos online
like this one but now the actions of two
male coaches in their 20s have damaged
the lives
of two teenage swimmers on a scale of
one to ten the alarms should have been
going off
at a rate of fifteen robert allen
represents one of the young victims from
stockton
they were allowed to roam and seek out
their prayer without any type of
restriction whatsoever and as a result
my 13 year old client was molested and
raped repeatedly by a swim coach it
began with a series of text messages
sent by a coach named marco villadueva
to another teenage girls swimmer
there was information given to usa
swimming
where the coach in fact admitted to
engaging in social media
interactions with a minor during which
he discussed
sexual activity including the terms
getting
laid well i have a friend who wants to
get laid also
you come through for me i can come
through for you the coach wrote
according to court finance
you've been flaking on me now basically
i have your
vagina hahaha lol
hey i need a cuddle partner he was
transporting her
in his car alone he was
engaging in classic red flag predatory
behavior
and in violation of multiple code of
conduct
uh provisions and usa swimming by its
rules
should have put him through the national
board of review procedure
and should have banned him instead usa
swimming let him off with a mere warning
and did not do anything
else to to correct clearly chaotic
situation in stockton
he wasn't suspended he wasn't banned
after that sort of language that kind of
texting back and forth
the only thing they did was cover it up
they did not alert anybody
at this club as to the allegations so no
one knew what he what he was accused of
doing and what he admitted to doing
they simply confidentially and quietly
sent him a letter
saying don't do this again and if you do
there'll be harsher consequences that is
a cover-up allard says
the decision to go easy on the coach was
made at the headquarters of usa swimming
in colorado springs colorado it's the
organization that oversees
some 3 000 swim clubs across the country
the usa swimming uh code of conduct
rules require that the
executive director in this case tim
hinchey
sign off on any decision as to whether
or not to discipline
a coach accused of in this case
predatory behavior
and he signed off on it this went to the
very top and if the rules were followed
he would have been apprised of the
situation and would have
agreed with the decision already says
that failure to take action
emboldened this coach shunichi fujisama
who molested and raped his client
starting at the age of 12.
predictably when you have a coach doing
these things
and they're put up for discipline and no
disciplinary action happens at all it
sets the expectation at the club that
these types of
behaviors are allowed and it was a
copycat type process
where uh the coach who molested my
client
uh who was coaching uh right alongside
marco villanueva
and afterwards after he left the coach
fujishima
pleaded guilty and is now serving 12
years in prison
a development that made big news across
california
and raised even more questions allard
says about the role of usa swimming
failing to deal with the earlier case or
even notify parents
this would have never happened it was a
simple phone call that they should have
made
and they failed to do because they were
too busy trying to cover it up
an investigation by the law and crime
network has found that there are
hundreds of young swimmers who have been
sexually abused by coaches in the last
five years alone
like this young woman in north carolina
who was 14
when her coach began to sexually abuse
her i feel guilty all the time
and it physically and mentally hurts not
to cry
her coach is now in prison and she and
her family are also
suing usa swimming for creating a
climate and culture
that tolerates such abuse you've got
coaches who see these people that look
like grown women that are
running around in swimsuits
and i think that just invites some of
the bad behavior that we
have unfortunately seen with usa
swimming coaches
the usa swimming president tim hinchey
told congress the sport is instituting
what he calls
a safe sport program for all of its
member clubs
we have a number of new initiatives
underway and we are vetting even more
the safe sport recognized club program
will enhance
athlete protection efforts at all levels
especially the local level
while we cannot change the past we will
learn from it and we will do better
our commitment to preventing child
sexual abuse and providing a safe
and healthy environment for our athletes
is constant
and long lasting usa swimming would not
tell us nationwide
how many of us clubs are certified as
safe sport clubs
and when we tried to ask kinchie about
it at the swimming fundraiser
he walked away from our cameras can you
tell me right now how many i'm not sure
but why not why can't you talk because
i'm here hosting people i know these are
important questions
sir how many recognized safe sport clubs
exist today
can you answer that question sir and now
the wall street journal is reporting
that federal prosecutors in new york
have opened a criminal investigation
of usa swimming which comes as no
surprise to bob allert
number one they're failing to contact
the authorities
because on a kind of the fact that they
are mandated reporters
number two the cover-up of uh of
pedophilia
is a crime and number three is when you
force these athletes to have sex
as a condition of them being able to
compete at the highest lay
levels that's forced sexual labor and
that's a crime
and is there evidence that the coaches
are demanding sex in
return for placing the swimmers in uh
the best position the best meets
in every case that's part of the
grooming process that's how they get
these uh young ladies to to do what
they want them to do which is to engage
in sex acts with them
it's absolutely a carrot hung over their
head that if you want to advance in the
swimming world
if you want to go to the olympic games
if you want to represent america
this is the price you have to pay
representing the united states of
america
michael phelps we invited uss swimming
to provide someone to come on our
program tonight and respond to these
increasingly serious allegations
and the report that the organization is
now the focus of a criminal
investigation
by the u.s attorney's office here in new
york as first reported by the wall
street journal
but so far we've had no response none at
all
to our repeated inquiries and as to the
lawsuit over the stockton california
cases
usa swimming has said in court papers
that the allegations involving the coach
who sent those sexual snapchat messages
that they are
unproven calling them hysterical
accusations by the mother
that were investigated by stockton
police but did not lead to any criminal
charges
that coach also did not return our
messages seeking comment
up next has president trump made moves
that will allow
thousands of captured isis fighters to
go free
including those responsibles for the
murder of at least five american
journalists and aid workers
back now with growing concerns that a
decision by president trump to abandon
the kurd fighters
who helped the u.s fight isis will now
allow thousands of isis fighters to
escape
and once again pose a terror threat that
had been all but
extinguished even the president's
supporters are calling it irresponsible
as senator lindsey graham did in a
telephone call to fox news
i would hope people in the country want
allies in the war
so when somebody steps up and helps
america with isis which is a threat to
mankind
and we've had people killed in america
because of isis
inspiration so the kurds stepped up when
nobody else would to fight isis
if we abandon them good luck getting
anybody to help america in the future
with radical islam
al-qaeda and isis among those being held
in syria and could end up escaping now
are the isis men responsible for the
grisly murder of american
photojournalist james foley
and at least four other american
journalists and aid workers
and joining us now to talk about that is
diane foley james mother
who now runs the james a foley
foundation mrs foley thank you for
joining us what's going to happen there
do you think
well i just heard actually that um
our country has taken in custody the two
individuals
british jihadists who allegedly
kidnapped and tortured our four
americans in 2014.
so that is hopeful however i want to
make sure
they're going to come to this country
and face
a fair trial as opposed to being
held indefinitely i think it's
very important that we show the world
how justice can
can and should be served
in this regard so um i
am waiting to see um how this will be
handled
and have you been contacted by the white
house or the terror fusion center
not at all you know i
there i do have other concerns too brian
because
um these two alleged um uh
fighters are only two of ten thousand
men
and the actual leader al-baghdadi is
still at large
as are many of his fighters
so the thought of any of these
people be escaping
together with some of their um wives who
um also are um filled with this
this hatred um for the west
is very frightening and certainly a
national security risk
of course and as you say the fact that
uh the two men have been taken to
custody
al baghdadi is still out there and the
people who gave the orders are still out
there
exactly exactly brian and
you know i would hope that we would take
leadership of an international coalition
to seek justice for all the human rights
atrocities that
isis has imposed on this part of the
world this is
a question for you from our control room
from executive producer
rhonda schwartz rhonda what's your
question diane thanks again for joining
us tonight
there are westerners still being held
hostage
and missing austin tyson american
what's your concern does this situation
complicate any hope of rescuing
finding those missing people well i
certainly pray not um you know
but one does not know if turkey
starts more of the violence at the
northern border
it is really hard to know what
in in in turn president
assad will choose to do i've heard he's
already reached out to the kurds to join
their alliance
which will further complicate a lot of
this
and we really need to find al-baghdadi
and the rest of the
leadership of this terrorist group
because i do not feel they are totally
defeated at all
and if we step out and do not provide
our support in leadership to me that
risk
increases that this terrorism will
regroup
and come back to threaten us again and
mrs foley you also i know have hopes at
some point for the return of your son's
body and the remains of the other
americans who died there
sure of course um
but jim was only one of hundreds of
thousands of victims um this is truly
uh human rights um atrocity
and i just i'm hopeful
that the international community would
come together
and put all of these fighters on trial
because we we need answers and we need
to
stand together against this threat
indeed diane foley thank you so much for
joining us tonight the legacy of your
son james remains very much alive thanks
to your work
up next our shout out for the
investigative tv reporter in minnesota
who exposed some ugly truths
about what was happening to teenage
girls in his state and why the state's
judges
often went easy on the men responsible
when we return
our shout out tonight for the
investigative reporter at a minnesota tv
station who with his team broke
newground the scourge of sex trafficking
and how the state's judges were often
going easy on the men
enslaving teenage girls as prostitutes
hi everyone and welcome to u.s bank
stadium in downtown minneapolis and to
the bowl of north and super bowl 52.
this investigation started because we
had a super bowl here in
minnesota in 2018 and with that super
bowl there was a lot of talk about
sex trafficking so our investigative
unit really wanted to go
deeper on this subject aj lago and his
team at
care 11 tv in minneapolis-st paul soon
uncovered
a shocking reality that had remained
well hidden
and the more we dug into it the more we
started finding reports that minnesota
here in the middle of the country
on some major highways is in some cases
ground zero for
sex trafficking and people passing
through going to oil fields
or crossing from you know a port in
duluth that has big ships coming in
heading down to chicago
and you know some of your other cities
through the heart of the country
so that must have been quite a surprise
for your viewers certainly
i think it really was i betcha there was
a lot of
really our backyard kind of questions
that
pop up when we started exposing 911
where's your emergency
i need help what kind of help do you
need there's three people trying to
prostitute me
and they brought the story to life with
a focus on one 16 year old girl
who they called jodell if they see me
they're going to kill me
this is the police car camera tape of
that young girl being rescued
[Music]
she and her friend had run away from
home in duluth and fell into the hands
of two men
who began to sell them the girls were
taken to this st
paul motel room 229
is where jodel's hell began i had a
knife
put up to my neck when i was being raped
we had some really poignant interviews
especially with a young lady who was
willing to
share some really horrific details of
what happened to her
and her experience to showcase why this
was
such a problem and how did he get those
incredible police tapes of her
as she was expressing her fear of what
was going on
really that took more work than just
about anything else in this
investigation because the police were
understandably loath to release those
eventually ended up working with the
victims and she allowed us to share them
and in some of the other police videos
it was really just
identifying key cases that had you know
made headlines across the state
you know in the months and years prior
but hadn't really been delved into in a
really
with a really serious spotlight but what
took this investigative reporting to a
higher level
was what lago and his team discovered in
area courts
once the men responsible were brought to
justice huge numbers
able to avoid what was supposed to be a
mandatory financial fine
with the money used to help victims when
we analyze
seven years of statewide court data we
found
from 2011 to 2017 there were 196
traffickers sentenced but 118 of them
60 percent had no prostitution
assessment
imposed the more we kept pulling that
string
you know initially we found okay judges
aren't imposing these fines that are
supposed to be mandatory
and short-changing victims of sex
trafficking
well then we flipped it on its head and
we said okay what's happening with the
money
when judges actually do impose and when
we did that
we found that the money that was bylaws
supposed to be going for very specific
things taking care of
police basically prosecutors just for
training
handle these cases the money was missing
misplaced
misused it was going into general funds
and it wasn't being used the way the law
required so we found that and we kept
digging on that and then we found
some some cases we found money going
directly into a prosecutor's pocket
as a bonus for getting convictions
which was maybe the most shocking thing
we found and when the k-11 team sought
reaction from the judges
not a single judge in the state would
talk with us
including the judge who handled the case
involving 16-year-old joe dell
whose abusers were convicted but not
required to pay the mandatory fine
we emailed judge merrick asking why the
failure to fine
she refused to be interviewed responding
i do not comment on my cases
nor on my decision-making process it's
the kind of work that does not come
easily or
quickly this story took months to
prepare before
it ever went on air we're juggling other
projects at the same time
but i spent weeks just in a records room
reading through cases to get an
understanding of how
sex trafficking cases work to hit our
judicial system
our unit has myself but has producer
steve
eckert who i know you know from his
dateline days what do you say to those
stations that aren't doing this kind of
work with that kind of investment and
backing you need to give
your crews time to do this kind of
journalism
because this is what our job is it's to
hold
people accountable it's to shine a light
in places
that you're not going to be able to in a
day
and to help end a culture that has for
too long
tolerated cases like that of jodel
they're going to kill me because when
there is no one else's
[Applause]
and so a well-deserved shout out to aj
and his executive prisoner steve
eckert a long time colleague back when i
worked with him at nbc news
so nice to see him still at it bringing
along a great new generation of
investigative reporters
that's our program for tonight thanks
for joining us we'll see you back here
next week
you